hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute mal nicht aus der küche aber
dennoch ein sehr gefragtes video ich
zeige euch heute wie ich meine wäsche
wasche wie klingt ein bisschen banal
wenn ich das so sage aber immer wenn ich
es gemacht habe kam von euch ganz viele
fragen die habe ich gesammelt ich zeige
euch heute zum einen wie so meine
waschmaschine ist und zum anderen was
ihr eben beachten müsst bei der
waschmaschine beim textil sortieren beim
waschmittel aussuchen oder auch bei bike
spieler also welcher routine ich kann
euch jetzt nicht sagen dass ich täglich
wasche oder einmal die woche oder zwei
mal die woche da müsst ihr natürlich
auch selber gucken wie er bedarf ist wir
sind ja mittlerweile ein
vier-personen-haushalt am anfang waren
wir zwei personen pro watt und ich und
da hat auch einmal die woche ausgereicht
ich hatte auch noch eine andere
waschmaschine und wir hatten einfach
eine andere routine mittlerweile gucke
ich einfach immer so je nach bedarf mann
haben wir mehr mal weniger mal was ich
täglich manchmal auch nur einmal die
woche
da guck dir einfach selber was ich aber
am allerwichtigsten finde ist wo ist
denn euer waschraum überhaupt wird ihr
nämlich jetzt gerade noch beim bau seit
oder plant irgendwann zu bauen oder ein
haus kauft und grundsaniert oder
vielleicht in eurer wohnung alles ein
bisschen umgestalten könnte ich sagen
aller allerbesten dass die waschmaschine
nicht im keller steht wo sie bei 80
prozent der menschen steht sondern dort
wo die wäsche anfällt ich meine früher
hat man das schon so gemacht dass die
waschmaschine im keller verschwunden ist
waschmaschine und trockner waren aber
auch sehr laut früher also es war
wirklich ein hubschrauber geräusch und
man sollte eben dieses geräusch nicht in
der wohnung haben hatten natürlich auch
platz technische probleme und dann hat
man immer unten alles verstaut aber
mittlerweile denke ich einfach für mich
im alltag ist es einfach sehr unlogisch
wenn die waschmaschine im keller ist ich
aber im zweiten obergeschoss brenne und
dort mein schlafzimmer habe mich dort
umziehen
die wäsche dort entsteht denn man spart
sich einfach ganz ganz viele laufwege in
unserer alten wohnung war es so da
hatten wir also in der ersten wohnung
also da hat mir die waschmaschine
einfach im badezimmer drin
ganz praktisch das war auch samira
wickelkommode sozusagen
ich habe einfach die auflage gehabt dort
hatte ich natürlich bisschen wenig platz
und in unserer letzten wohnungen die wir
eben vor diesem haus hatten war es so
dass die waschmaschine im keller war und
für mich als frau war es dann aber
extrem schwierig nicht weil ich schwach
bin sondern weil einfach die wäsche sehr
schwer ist die wäsche vom dritten
obergeschoss also von der dachwohnung in
den keller runter zu tragen die nasse
wäsche die er dann noch mehr weg wieder
nach oben zu tragen und deswegen habe
ich gesagt wenn wir ein haus bauen dann
ist der waschraum hier oben direkt neben
dem schlafzimmer wo einfach jeder ganz
kurze laufwege hat und deswegen ist hier
unser hauswirtschaftsraum also ich habe
zwei haus wirtschaftsräume der eine ist
unten das ist mir so der vorratsraum bei
der küche und der andere ist eben hier
oben und ihr seht auch schon ist ein
sehr kleiner raum
aber der hat echt in sich also da ist
wirklich alles richtig praktisch und
funktional
ich zeige euch gleich noch ein bisschen
mehr dazu aber zuerst einmal gehen wir
jetzt wirklich ans wäsche waschen und
bevor man die wäsche richtig waschen
kann sollte man sie zu einem richtig
sortieren als motto nicht am anfang
zusammengezogen sind da habe ich mir
natürlich noch nicht so viele gedanken
darüber gemacht das war ja auch mein
erster haushalt und wir hatten am anfang
eine wäsche tonne da haben wir praktisch
die ganze wäscherin gesammelt und ende
der woche freitags mal war es meistens
muss ich dann natürlich die wäsche
sortieren damit ich die wäsche richtig
waschen konnte und es ist dann immer
ausgeartet denn dann habe ich alles in
der badewanne sortiert da hatte ich so
ein hügel mit weißer wäsche in hügel mit
bunter wäsche hügel handtücher und
buntwäsche und so weiter macht hat sich
natürlich immer tiere ströme aufgeregt
weil ich freitags man nicht alles
geschafft habt und das ding dann aber du
musst das halt immer ausräumen zum baden
oder zum duschen und dann habe ich
gelernt und habe gesagt okay wir machen
uns drei welsche tonnen und das heißt
wir hatten dann schon drei eine weiß
eine verbund eine für dunkel war jetzt
auch nicht so ideal weil du musst es
dann praktisch jedes mal deckel hoch
wäschereien und dann habe ich gesagt
wenn sie irgendwo einen waschraum haben
dann möchte ich ein wurf schächte haben
viele haben ja auch so eine wäscherei
einem einwurf schacht der dann praktisch
in den keller führt das vielleicht noch
ganz kurz zum ort des waschraums
natürlich ist es nicht möglich oder
nicht immer möglich den waschraum dort
zu haben wo man ihn eben haben möchte
und viele haben ihn eben
keller und dann kann man sich wirklich
so ein becher schacht machen wo die
wäsche runtergeschmissen wird und dort
landet aber wie gesagt hoch tragen muss
man sie dann trotzdem
hier habe ich jetzt endlich einen
schrank und da war es mir auch ganz
wichtig dass er wirklich hier vorne
diese öffnungen hat und ich einfach die
wäsche hier reinschmeißen kann ich hier
meine wäsche in schwarze dunkle bunte
hell bunt und weiße wäsche und habe dann
noch vier weitere fächer und zwar heller
handtücher dunkle handtücher putztücher
und handwäsche ambientes system von
schiller schule baut nicht nur küchen
sondern eben auch waschräume haus
wirtschaftsräume wie sie clean heißen
die und da kann man sich wirklich alles
wunderbar am zusammenstellen lassen und
planen und es ist einfach super
funktional und praktisch und die gibt es
auch in jedem küchen fachgeschäft also
können wir gerne mal schauen und ich hab
das jetzt hier so gemacht dass ich hier
einfach diesen einen schrank habe diese
einwurf schlechte habt und da drinnen
sind nämlich auch schon direkt die
wäschekörbe dazu und diese passenden
wäschekörbe die sind da drin
das heißt man kommt dann her und
schmeißt die wäscherei ich habe jetzt
hier beschriftet ich wollte ursprünglich
so bunte schrift damit samira auch ohne
zu lesen wissen was reinkommt
aber die zwei bzw l kommt sowieso nur
hier unten dran und da habe ich dann
einfach so gemacht dass schwarze löcher
hier oben ist das heißt da kommen morath
und ich dran und samira hat die haben
meist gar nichts schwarzes ich habe ich
dann dunkle bunte wäsche da kommt die
samira schon ganz gut dran und ella
legten einfach auf den boden
hier unten helle bunte wäsche und ganz
unten weiß das sind so die die wir auch
am meisten brauchen und schwarz brauchte
murat am meisten und da hat man einfach
wirklich den vorteil ihr schmeißt die
schmutzige wäsche rain man muss sie
nicht mehr anfassen man muss nicht mehr
in der dreckigen wäsche herumwühlen und
hat einfach direkt alles sortiert und
wirklich ein arbeitsgang weniger und
einfach ganz ganz viel zeitersparnis
ich muss immer wieder kontrollieren ob
nicht doch was falsches wort gelandet
ist aber das sehe ich dann spätestens
dann wenn eben die wäsche dann zur
waschmaschine geht ja beim wäsche
trennen ist einfach nur wichtig dass ihr
wisst was gibt es für textilien dh die
textilen solltet ihr schon ganz gut
kennen und das etikett innen lesen
und da sind ja auch die wäsche symbole
und da sieht man einfach so dass man
nach dem empfindlichsten geht das heißt
wenn du zum beispiel sportkleidung habt
die auf synthetischen stoffen besteht
dann solltet ihr die nicht unbedingt bei
60 grad waschen
schaut einfach auf die wäsche symbole
vielleicht können wir auch einfach kurz
auf ein paar eingehen ich nehme jetzt
einfach mal hier ein kleid das ist noch
ganz neu ich habe es jetzt auch auf
links gedreht und dann hat er hier immer
noch das etikett wo immer ziemlich viel
drauf steht
und ich hab ich sogar noch ein knopf
guck mal beim knopf mache ich so das ist
ja sowieso das zweite etikett das
schneidig dann meist weg ich auch oft
mit scheren symbol und damit ich den
ersatz knopf nicht verliere habe ich
natürlich natürlich hier hinten so ein
gefäß und da sammle ich alles da kommt
der knopfreihen zeigt und nähzeug und
wenn ich dann mal einen verlierer kennt
ihn wieder dran nehmen
guck mal hier steht sogar schon roche
inside out also auf links waschen das
heißt einfach einmal umdrehen dass die
farbe innen ist und das innenteil außen
das besteht zu 100 prozent aus viskose
und jetzt habe ich hier die einzelnen
symbole und die sind meist auf jedem
textil wirklich vorhanden
also hier vorne ist ein reh subotic da
steht immer drin dass man es machen kann
dann auch wie viel grad 30 60 40 90 und
wenn da so ein strich drunter ist dann
bedeutet es einfach pflege waschgang in
der waschmaschine dann habe ich hier
noch das dreieck symbol dieses bedeutet
gleichen bzw nicht gleichen
das viereck mit dem kreis bedeutet
trockner beim besitzer trockner
durchgestrichen aber es gibt auch beim
trockner unterschiede da gibt's dann
eben gut trocknen und heiß trocknen oder
eben auch schonend trocknen das steht
dann da eben auch mit drauf dann gibt es
ein symbol war es viele wahrscheinlich
nicht kennen und zwar das viereck mit
dem strich drinnen
das bedeutet nämlich also ich hab jetzt
hier einen vertikalen strich das
bedeutet ich kann das kleid später nach
dem waschen ich darf nicht trocknen aber
ich kanns hängend sozusagen trocknen und
dann gibt es auch welche mit
horizontalen strichen das bedeutet wie
zum beispiel bei wollpullover dass man
die einfach liegen tropfnass trocknet
damit die sich eben beim trocknen nicht
aushängen
das ist auch ganz wichtig zu wissen ich
darf mein kleid auf bügeln
da ist auch dass bügel symbol dass sie
dann auch immer ein punkt zwei punkte
oder 3 punkte mit dabei und dieses
symbol hier bedeutet nicht chemisch
reinigen hat aber eigentlich auch für
zuhause jetzt keine bedeutung denn das
war sowieso in der textil wäscherei oder
eben an der einigungsstelle so das sind
die einzelnen symbole da solltet ihr
wirklich drauf achten und natürlich hat
man ja nicht immer kleidungsstücke die
einwandfrei optimal zusammenpassen das
heißt ja wir dieses kleid dann habe ich
aber auch vielleicht auch ein baumwoll
oberteile sportbekleidung und beim
sortieren achtet ihr einfach drauf
schaut so gut wie möglich dass die
textilien einigermaßen zusammen passen
auch farblich natürlich und wenn ich
dann aber textilien habe wie zum
beispiel der feine bluse oder mbh die
wasche ich natürlich nicht einfach so
mit sondern habe einfach einen korb für
handwäsche die sammle ich hier drin und
dann passiert da wirklich auch nichts
dann geht es jetzt eigentlich direkt ans
wäschewaschen wichtig ist dass ihr ein
programm aus wählt was dann wirklich für
die textilien gedacht ist die am
empfindlichsten sind also wenn ich jetzt
hier mein viskose kleid habe und aber
auch noch was aus baumwolle drin hat
baumwolle verträgt so etwas mehr
temperatur viskose eben jetzt nicht so
stark und er pflegeleicht dann nehme ich
eben doch die pflegeleicht stufe damit
wirklich nichts kaputt geht oder wir
waschen jetzt ich habe hier unten so
eine schublade und da kann ich jetzt ein
wäschekorb draufstellen
und wir haben hier einfach drauf
geachtet dass die waschmaschine und
trockner weil ich eben viel wäsche
wasche auf augenhöhe sind das heißt ich
muss mich einfach nicht komplett runter
bücken unter der waschmaschine habe ich
noch eine schublade zeige ich euch
gleich und ich glaube eine der
häufigsten fragen ist wie voll darf die
waschmaschine sein wie viel darf man sie
beladen und da müsst ihr wegs darauf
achten dass sie nicht zu voll ist also
früher hat man echt oft gesagt wenn sie
nicht voll ist dann lohnt sich waschen
nicht da ging es natürlich auch im
wasser strom und eben auch waschmittel
es ist aber leider so dass wenn die
waschmaschine zu voll ist fehlt auch die
mechanik dh die textilien können ja
nicht gut schwimmen der das waschpulver
oder waschmittel verteilt sich nicht gut
ihr könnt rückstände davon haben flecken
davon bekommen und das wasser kann eben
auch nicht alles schön ausspülen
das heißt ich berate das jetzt hier mal
und acht natürlich auch nochmal auf die
textilien passt auf und ist jetzt so die
dunkle buntwäsche normalerweise bin ich
ganz viele sachen hab teile ich noch
zwischen blau und grüner wäsche und
roter wäsche aber weil ich jetzt einfach
nicht so viel habe passt dass hier das
hat sich dann noch ein handtuch mit rein
verirrt das kommt ob wir hier oben rein
handtücher dunkel und ich habe jetzt
einfach wirklich noch ganz gut platz
hier in der waschmaschine ist könnte
auch was rein passen wir noch eine große
waschmaschine
ich sehe das auch hier weil hier reiten
dran steht wird die wäsche einlegen
maximal neun kilogramm das heißt ich
habe eine waschmaschine die eben auch
die beratungs menge erkennt die die
textil art erkennt und den
verschmutzungsgrad eigentlich muss man
da fast gar nichts mehr alleine machen
aber ihr könnt auch einfach als
faustregel schauen wenn eure hand oben
als faust noch ganz gut reinpasst dann
ist es okay dann solltet ihr nicht mehr
wäschereien geben und ich kann die
waschmaschine jetzt hier diese zu
entwarf zu drei viertel beladen ist
jetzt aber auch okay weil ich wie gesagt
eine automatik waschmaschine habt und
die nimmt dann eben entsprechend weniger
wasser entsprechend weniger waschmittel
und dadurch ist es dann wirklich okay
ich habe jetzt hier bunt gemischte
textilien drin das heißt feines
pflegeleichtes aber auch so karo hemden
die jetzt nicht so ganz fein sind
deswegen werde ich jetzt aber ein
pflegeprogramm
und ich zeige es euch jetzt mal einmal
weiß wie man es macht wenn man es
manuell macht und zwar nehmt ihr euch
euer waschmittel da solltet ihr
unbedingt darauf achten dass er ein
waschmittel verwendet was zum einen
hautfreundlich ist vielleicht keine duft
und farbstoffe drin hat weil sie einen
landen die alle in der umwelt zum
anderen auf der haut und ich bin auch
nicht perfekt ich versuche jetzt
wirklich überall nach und nach zu
schauen dass ich wirklich umsteigen kann
und vieles ersetzen kann
es gibt auch waschnüsse es gibt auch
kastanien waschmittel als ich bin mir da
selber hat noch ein bisschen am einlesen
und ich habe jetzt hier einst zum einen
weniger plastik hat weil es eben keine
flasche ist und zum anderen ist auch
vegan weil was in flüssigwaschmittel und
bei spielern drin ist wenn man oft
eigentlich gar nicht wissen
schlachtabfälle sind oft mit drin
rindertalg ist mit drin und ich glaube
darauf will man in seiner wäsche
zumindest auf jeden fall verzichten
ich habe jetzt hier einst auch die erler
ganz gut verträgt und ihr achtet jetzt
drauf je nachdem welche mir drin hat und
wie viel ihr drin habt dann habt ihr auf
der rückseite bei jedem waschmittel
immer einfach die anwendung
verschmutzungsgrad ihr habt die
wasserhärte und ihr habt natürlich die
wäsche
das heißt wenn ihr keine waschmaschine
habt mit einem automatik programm war
einfach die waschmaschine selber das
waschmittel dosiert dann achtet bitte
auf die rückseite verwendet nicht so
viel waschmittel
denn das problem ist es wird dadurch
nicht sauberer sondern das waschmittel
verfängt sich in euren textilien und
trat später wenn es dann im trockner
lande kann sogar passieren dass ihr
dadurch noch mehr flecken habt als
vorher
also wirklich immer gut dosieren und
nicht überdosieren spart etwas geld
spart
etwas umweltverschmutzung und natürlich
ist ganz hautfreundlich starke
verschmutzungen habt dann probiert mit
gallseife die wird einfach auf gebürstet
dann lass ich es einwirken und dann
kommt ganz regulär mit in die wäsche
[Musik]
ich hab das jetzt hier so dass ich
einmal nur mein waschmittel auffüllen
muss man hat ja in seiner waschmaschine
einmal und fach für waschmittel einmal
für weichspüler und ich jetzt noch ein
drittes fach eben für manuelle wäsche
und wie gesagt habe ich jetzt hier die
waschmaschine mit eidos das heißt die
waschmaschine erkennt von ganz alleine
diebe ladungsmenge die textil art und
den verschmutzungsgrad und ich muss nur
einmal mein waschmitteln
flüssigwaschmittel auffüllen und die
waschmaschine das jetzt dann von ganz
alleine sie zieht sich wasser von ganz
alleine und wählt eben auch das programm
von ganz alleine was hier noch dazu
sagen kann wie gesagt ich habe hier drei
kammern und die waschmittel kammer hat
1,3 liter fassungsvermögen das heißt man
wirklich nur einmal auf und hat dann
einfach 30 waschgänge lang ungefähr
wirklich die ruhe und muss nichts mehr
auffüllen ich habe jedoch den
weichspüler und warum wir keinen
weichspüler benutzen hat wirklich
verschiedene faktoren zum einen kann man
sich wirklich ein haufen geld sparen
zum anderen ist er der weichspüler dafür
da um die wäsche weich zu machen die
wäsche wird durch den waschvorgang weil
zum beispiel das wasser zu hart ist wenn
ihr aber zu hartes kaltes wasser habt
könnt ihr entweder esse ich mir dazu
geben essigessenz oder etwas natron oder
ihr könnt ganz einfach eine bwt anlage
also eine enthärtungsanlage verwenden
die sowieso ganz gut ist denn so bleiben
eure rohre eure waschmaschinen und die
geschirrspülmaschine einfach auch
verschont und sie leben eben auch viel
länger der weichspüler ist er weiß was
nach dem waschvorgang also nachdem
ausspülen einfach nochmal in die
wäschetrommel mit rein gespült wird und
sich dann um die textilfasern liegt und
jetzt könnt euch vor was dann passiert
der weichspüler landet zum einen eben
auch in der umwelt als auch flusswasser
er landet aber auch auf eurer haut und
jemand der wirklich empfindlich ist wie
meine ella zum beispiel die merken dass
eben auch sofort also ganz viele
hautausschläge ganz viele hautreizungen
und trockene haut neurodermitis
entstehen dadurch dass man einfach
weichspüler verwendet was dadurch auch
entsteht ist gestand der waschmaschine
denn normalerweise reinigt sicher die
waschmaschine während dem ausspülen
aber wenn ihr weichspüler benutzt dann
bleiben die reste eben auch in der
waschmaschine und dadurch kann es eben
passieren dass sich bakterien ansammeln
die waschmaschine stinkt und dadurch
eben auch die wäsche wenn sie mal eine
stunde drin liegt eben auch schon muffig
riecht
und dann beginnt der teufelskreis denn
wofür gewaschen schiene macht man noch
mehr weiß spielereien und es endet im
prinzip nie ein spieler legt sich eben
um die textilfasern und verändert aber
auch dann die eigenschaft eure textilien
also wenn ihr sportbekleidung zum
beispiel habt und die soli rat muss
aktiv sein und den schweiß und die
feuchtigkeit vom körper nach außen
tragen kann sie dann nicht mehr machen
weil sich eben der weichspüler um die
fasern legt das heißt ihr schwitzen noch
mehr läufer kleidung wolle und seide
wird zum beispiel schwierig frottee
handtücher die saugen keine feuchtigkeit
mehr auf oder auch geschirrhandtücher
und dinge wie elasthan oder auch jeans
die beulen sich einfach schneller aus
weil der weichspüler das elasthan mit
angreift und so wie ich fragen kurz
erwähnt habe sind einfach oft
schlachtabfälle im wald spieler mit
dabei und wenn ihr euch jetzt vorstellt
der weichspüler der wäscht sich nicht
aus der wäsche raus sondern bleibt als
letzte schicht auf den textilien dann
landet das ganze auf ihrer kleidung und
im endeffekt auf eurer haut und ich
glaube auch gerade der umwelt der haut
und der kostenfaktor sind wirklich
gründe warum man einfach keine
weichspüler verwenden sollte so will zum
beispiel und man kann ja auch seine
wäsche wieder weich bekommen indem man
einen trockner benutzt oder eben
bügeleisen da kommen wir später dazu wie
gesagt ich habe bei mir mein waschmittel
schon aufgefüllt das reicht mir jetzt
auch noch ich bekomme das auch angezeigt
ansonsten rechnet ihr euch jetzt einfach
aus die meisten waschmittel hersteller
liefern ja auch so einen kleinen becher
mit dazu und da könnt ihr dann euer
waschmittel ein film ich habe im
waschmittel für buntes das geht dann für
so 20 bis 60 grad wäsche ein waschmittel
für weißwäsche ist auch empfehlenswert
weil da einfach bleichmittel drin sind
die eben eure weiße wäsche auch weiß
bleiben lassen und wenn ihr braucht
könnt ihr euch noch ein feinwaschmittel
für wolle seite
und wenn ich dann braucht er das eben
nicht ich acht einfach immer darauf dass
nicht so viele duft und farbstoffe drin
sind weil eben das wird die haut jetzt
nicht ganz so gut
okay ich habe jetzt hier meine wäsche
drin und wird jetzt im normalfall
einfach hier stufe pflegeleicht wählen
ich kann mich einmal kurz hier die
ganzen stufen zeigen
ich habe ich meinen baumwolle programm
für handtücher oder auch für bettwäsche
zum beispiel baumwolle eco bedeutet
einfach etwas energie schonender und
wasser sparen da dauert aber ein
bisschen länger pflegeleicht eben für
pflegeleichte textilien und wenn man mal
was etwas nicht so schmutzig
dann einfach hier schnell mix ich habe
ich noch seide und wolle und auch noch
weitere programme die individuell
einstellen kann hier auf der linken
seite habe ich dann ein extra programm
für hemden und blusen ein extra
kurzprogramm wenn es mal richtig schnell
gehen muss allergie plus sportswear
pflegeleicht plus oder eben die beiden
automatikprogramme sanft und intensiv
ich nehme die automatik sanft weil die
waschmaschine daneben textil art erkennt
wasser und eben auch waschmittel richtig
dosiert sonst verbleibe ich mich jetzt
so sehr und wir kommen gar nicht mit dem
waschen und in der zeit kann ich schon
meine handlicher abhängen ich mache auch
alles immer ziemlich parallel oder putz
in der zeit des bat die haben sich da
hatte ich gestern abend schon gemacht
und hab es ja dann auch angetrocknet
also auf bügel trocken und hängen sie
dann aber gern noch mal auf damit so
schön platt sind
denn dann habe ich einfach eine schöne
schrank und platte handtücher
[Musik]
das bringe ich kurz die hand weg und
dann sage ich euch noch kurz den raum
wenn man hier reinkommt dann habe ich
hier eben wie gesagt waschmaschine und
trockner beides erhöht und eben auch
hier mit der schublade für den
wäschekorb dass ich den eben schon
ablegen kann
darunter habe ich dann jeweils eine
schublade hier rechts verstorben wie
toilettenpapier ist gerade ein bisschen
knapp aber wir kaufen das jetzt wieder
nach
und hier links habe ich das gleiche
darüber habe ich dann auch fächer habt
ihr diese körper eingestellt hier sollte
ich zum einen noch handtücher hell und
haben euch ja dunkel da oben habe ich
einfach so tragetaschen weil emi kommt
immer vor dass ich hier oben eine tasche
braucht ne tüte und dann hab ich nix
also wirklich irgendwann eingeführt ich
hab hier tragetaschen die schränke habe
ich bis komplett oben gebaut und auch
planen lassen
ich komme da auch so dran wenn nicht
habe ich auch in horn für den monat und
habe hier einfach noch staub fläche ich
muss aber dazu sagen dass ich da oben
noch gar nichts drin habe außer in zwei
drei schränken aber ich habe mir gedacht
irgendwann kriegt man das haus immer
voll und steuerung kann man immer
brauchen und befördern oben den schrank
zu stoppt mache ich lieber fächer hin
die verschlossen sind und da kann man
zum beispiel bettwäsche lagern winter
bettwäsche thema im sommer nicht braucht
oder sommer bettwäsche thema im winter
nicht braucht oder jacken die man nicht
anzieht
also ich denke stauraum ist eigentlich
immer ganz gut zwischen den beiden
maschinen habe ich hier einfach was ich
wirklich sehr lebe
denn hier oben habe ich eine stange sich
daneben auch nasse wäsche trocknen kann
hier dieses fach zum herausziehen und da
kann ich euch gleich wenn wir dann noch
was aufhängen was dazu sagen
hier unten habe ich immer noch körper
weil man die auch immer ganz gut
brauchen kann zum wegbringen oder mit
herholen hier oben habe ich dann auch
eben wie gesagt im schrank dann habe ich
hier das fach für putztücher und
handwäsche also für die schmutzige
wäsche hier verstorben ich meinen
waschmittel fahrrad und das ist auch
wirklich ganz gut denn so kann man
waschmittel ein verbrauch im angebot
kaufen kann es lagern einmal in die
waschmaschine einfüllen und fertig und
ich habe ich tatsächlich ein korb der
einfach leer ist man braucht auch leere
flächen denn voll kriegt man es immer
hier unten habe ich dann noch unsere
fußballer mit drin das ist hier auch
ganz praktisch und hier war so ein
kleines zwischen fach- und das ist ja
oft so ein toter raum aber der ist hier
gar nicht rot denn hier habe ich einfach
ein handtuch drin wenn ich hier nämlich
hände gewaschen habe kann ich mir hier
die hände abtrocknen und dass wirklich
jeder platz richtig gut durchdacht dann
gibt's hier hinten weiter links von der
waschmaschine habe ich offene regale
gewählt denn alles was offen ist ist
natürlich auch schnell greifbar das
heißt ich muss nicht noch einmal extra
an schrank öffnen und das ganze ist so
ein bisschen nach hinten versetzt also
selbst wenn es da mal unordentlich wäre
sieht man es eben nicht auf den ersten
blick aber ihr kennt mich ich muss immer
alles beschriften und etikette da wird
jeder weiß wo alles steht und hier habe
ich einfach die dinge die ich zum einen
für die waschmaschine oder trockner
braucht oder auch im waschbecken also
hier einfach so einfach für wäsche bis
jetzt ja für meine gallseife mit der ich
eben flecken behandle gerade wenn jetzt
die kinder essen trinken und spielen
oder auch ich mal make-up flecken auf
meinen oberteilen habt dann nehme ich
einfach keine seife ich habe ich noch
ein fach für spiele und essig weil die
auch bei mir regelmäßig im gebrauch sind
hier meine selbstgemachten reiniger wie
der wc reiniger oder ich hab auch natron
und zitronensäure immer da hier haben
wir zum auffüllen und handschuhe und
schwämme und auch da oben habe ich
wieder schränke zum verstauen aber die
sind auch bei mir momentan leer was ich
hier noch im hintergrund habe hier im
hintergrund habe ich eine organisations
wand und da habe ich zum einen meine
küchenrolle oder auch eine schere
schwämme meine wäschekörbe und die
organisations band die ist echt
praktisch denn hier kann ich alles hin
und herschieben
das heißt ich habe zwar die küchenrolle
aber wenn man die nicht braucht kann man
auch was anderes hinhängen und da habe
ich einfach in jeder ecke noch meine
steckdosenleiste hier unten meine
wäscheklammern und hier vorne auf diesen
kleinen haken noch meine spüle schwämme
und spült ersten dann habe ich hier vor
dem fenster einfach meinen waschbecken
was ich auch sehr wichtig finde in einem
waschraum denn man hat zum einen die
trockner flüssigkeiten hat aber auch mal
was zuvor waschen oder
zum behandeln zum händewaschen und das
ist ja auch der ort an dem ich eben
meine putts waren aufbewahren das
obergeschoss zu putzen
also bei uns waschbecken ganz wichtig
falls ihr euch wundert wie klappt das
mit dem waschbecken und der armatur und
dem fenster aber kann zum glück ja dann
werde es hin geplant und dann dachten
wir obst aber es gibt zum glück welche
die man einfach umknicken kann hier
unten habe ich einfach auch noch platz
und stauraum hier drüben ein auszug für
müll
ich habe hier einfach auch einen
müllbehälter und dann zimmer im prinzip
schon auf dieser seite
und da verstauen wir alles was wir an
kosmetik und so weiter für uns brauchen
also habe ich hier einen geschlossenen
hoch schrank weil ich da einfach nicht
so oft tragen muss und ich will einfach
auch da keine unordnung sehen also hier
oben habe ich auch alles schön
beschriftet das heißt hier oben ist mein
vorrat dann habe ich noch sachen wie
sonnenschutz oder haarstyling haarpflege
und shampoo hier sind wartet zum aus
stäbchen drin in kleinen kisten weil es
ansonsten wirklich einfach nur herum
fallen würde man hier noch ein paar mit
zehn produkte alles beschriftet und hier
unten einfach alles im durchsichtigen
kisten die man auch nach vorne ziehen
kann
ok irgendwie fällt mir jetzt auf das
konto nur einfach hat aber eher darauf
meine sachen mit benutzten und die
kinder sind hier nicht drin die kinder
haben ihren vorrat in ihrem bad aber ja
egal was soll's und er hat ja auch hier
seine zahnbürsten auch selbst
okay das reicht was ich hier noch hab
ist zum einen wasserkocher den ich auch
auf zum putzen benutze weil wir einfach
in der küche keine wasser cora mehr
brauchen induktionskochfeld ist nämlich
schneller
das heißt wenig toiletten putzen habe
ich jedem heißt wasser oder wenn man
sich doch mal tee aufgießen möchte oder
was auch immer
hier habe ich euch noch zettel und
stifte falls mir etwas fehlen
und hier ein körbchen für singles
nämlich hier single socken denn es
passiert immer das zocken verschwinden
und die landen dann hier und wenn sie
nach den menschen nicht mehr auftauchen
kann ich sie wegschmeißen und dann ist
das pärchen
oder der andere verschwunden und ich
habe hier noch meinen surfstick mein
mini stativ denn ich filme hier oft für
euch vielleicht falls 20 100 euro mit
ihren körbchen für singles was habe ich
hier noch ich habe hier eine schublade
das sind die sachen die ich in mein
hotel nein das sind die dinge die ich
aus dem hotel mit nehme die reise größen
die wir natürlich angefangen haben und
aus gründen der nachhaltigkeit nicht
wegschmeißen
das landet dann alles hier auch alles
schön sortiert dass es so einen
besteckkasten und da sieht man auch dass
schüler eben normalerweise auch küchen
macht und ich habe einfach den besteck
corp genommen und habe jetzt hier
sortiert hier habe ich super g los und
da habe ich shampoo de shampoo und haare
ich habe mich so gesicht hier ist
durchgehend und da habe ich alles für
lippen und zähne dann make up entferner
und vanille extrakt flaschen
ausgewaschen die eben auch die perfekte
reise größe sind da könnt ihr euch
nämlich waschmitteln oder deo oder creme
oder ein shampoo und das habe ich
einfach hier mit drin weil ich da platz
hatte hier unten habe ich auch wieder
stauraum dass er jetzt decken drin
handtücher und bettwäsche die ich
momentan einfach nicht so brauche und im
prinzip bleiben nur noch vier diese
großen schränke
ich habe ich ja die wäsche einwurf körbe
und hier auf der rechten seite ist so
eine organisation zu schrank der echt
super praktisch ist
ich habe hier zum einen mein bügelbrett
mein dampfreiniger der auch gleichzeitig
mein bügeleisen ist also das habe ich
auch hier und dann einfach auch
putzmittel also ich habe gesagt ich
putze auch hier oben ja ich putze und
verstaut hier auch alles also ich hab
hier zum einen die wischmopp auf setzte
dann noch zubehör zum dampfreiniger hier
habe ich reinigungsmittel hinten drin
und vorne dran einfach putztücher und
genauso auch hier damit einfach meine
kinder die sind gegensatz nicht dran
aber man weiß ja nie
deswegen kurz mittel waschmittel alles
immer oben lagern dass die kinder nicht
drankommen und wie gesagt habe ich
einfach putztücher davor ich komme ja
hinten
aber die kinder die sehen dass dann eben
nicht auf den ersten blick ich habe ich
noch meine fensterreiniger und da unten
einfach so zwei reisetaschen weil die da
perfekt reingepasst haben und so kann
ich wenn ich mal auf reisen gehen und
einfach mein make-up meine sachen
meinprospekt frau kann ich mir hier in
reisetaschen nimmt meine reise größen
einpacken und bin dann schnell stoppen
und hier habe ich dann noch so ein
freies fach mit stangen da kann ich
nämlich auf nasser wäsche aufhängen und
da werde ich ganz oft gefragt ob denn
die nasse wäsche im schrank nicht stinkt
also ich hänge ja den schrank dann nicht
voll
das heißt wenn ich jetzt gerade so wie
jetzt eine wäsche ladung laschet und
habe ich ja schon mal vier bereiche in
denen ich das aufhängen kann
hier habe ich noch den vorteil dass ich
hier die untere stange wegnehmen kann
also wenn ich mal lange kleider habe
mache ich einfach die stange kurz weg
hab dann eben ein langes fach und
ansonsten hänge ich ja wirklich keine
fünf wäsche ladungen direkt hier rein
also es trocknet wirklich alles ganz gut
aber meistens nutze ich sogar die
frische luft geht nach draußen und hängt
da die wäsche auf und hier verstehe ich
eben noch mein tritt den ich vielleicht
mal brauchen oder demokrat jetzt warten
wir kurz auf die erste wäsche lade und
dann zeige ich euch nämlich wie es mit
der wäsche weitergeht denn das richtige
sortieren ist das eine das richtige
waschen das andere aber nach dem waschen
ist umso wichtiger wie man die wäsche
weiter behandelt um dann eben das
lästige bügeln so sparen damit die
wäsche schön glatt wird gut durch
trocknet und eben frisch ist also die
wäsche ist gerade fertig aber ich hab
jetzt gerade noch zuschauerfragen
durchgelesen und die meistgestellte
frage ist zum einen woher ist deine
wäsche aufräumen schrank mit den
wäschekörben habe ich euch erklärt von
schüler- und zum anderen wollten einige
wissen wie groß der raum hier ist also
schmiss das noch kurz
238 mal 14 metern 73 273 also 238 mal
273 ungefähr 600 quadratmeter papa ich
drehe grad biochemie abriss baugrund
komisch mal distanz sind okay danke der
papa versteht immer noch nicht dass wenn
man telefoniert dass man nicht schreien
muss wir sind die türkei also ich bin
echt gerade beeindruckt sechseinhalb
quadratmeter ich dachte tatsächlich sind
auch so 7 halbgott einen quadratmeter
mehr oder weniger aber ich muss halt
sagen dass der mega funktionale raum
also auf 60 quadratmetern kann ich mir
die ganze macht jetzt erstmal wäsche
laden raus ist nichts mehr drin
dann geht es hier direkt weiter und zum
zeit sparen natürlich gleich die nächste
wäscherei nehmen helle wäsche hh kann
man hier etwas dunkles entdeckt und was
weiß und bei murat muss ich immer gucken
ob er noch was im winter schon hat also
da wäre ich schon längst reicht hier
bleibe ich auf automatik sanft wie
gesagt dass wir jetzt auch wieder so ein
pflegeleicht programm 30 grad mit
bisschen waschmittel drinnen im
waschmittel freue mich auch viele da ist
ja einfach mit einem strich und zwei
strichen also vorwäsche und optische und
wenn ihr keine vor vischer habt müsst
ihr da natürlich auch nichts einführen
aber es steht auch bei euch an eure
waschmaschine
aber wie gesagt ich mache hier meist
immer das automatikprogramm und jetzt
geht es hier über jetzt habe ich hier
meine gewaschene wäsche und davon landen
ein paar sachen im trockner aber nicht
zum komplett trockenen sondern nur zum
antrocknen denn wenn ihr wäsche an
trocknet und sie danach auf hängt dann
spart ihr euch meisten fürs bügeln und
ich mein baby gehört es nicht wirklich
zu meinen hobbys wann wir dies macht man
sich schon gern aber so mich zum bügeln
aufzuraffen und das nicht ich sollte
jetzt mal alles was ich nicht in den
trockner schmeißen darf kommt hier nach
links
alles was bisschen trockener darf hier
und was ich gerne ganz komplett durch
trockene das in eben handtücher und
bettwäsche zum beispiel weil da haben
wir einfach den vorteil dass die hatte
ich einfach wieder schön weich werden
sie bleiben dann nicht so dunkel so
meine caros die durch auch mal ein
bisschen zumindest
vor trocknen
nach dieser ganzen gürtel immer war
da kommt auch nicht rein okay hier beim
trockner habe ich auch das gleiche also
ich habe zum einen dieser ganzen
programme wir haben jetzt im trockner
daher das wasser flacher
wir haben nicht dran gedacht vorher der
wasserleitung nach außen zu legen für
ein trockner aber was es auch gibt und
zwar habe ich das drüben da hab ich
nämlich einen wasch trockner und er
benutzt dann praktisch das trockner
wasser auch zum waschen und das ist halt
echt praktisch aber ich wollte hier zwei
geräte haben damit sie eben parallel
arbeiten kann und jetzt gehe ich hier
eben einfach auf pflegeleicht und
schwere jetzt hier nicht schrank trocken
das ist mir dann zu trocken ich will ja
noch hängen sondern weggebügelt rocken
mieterschutz gibt es hier auch und was
ich bei meinen waschmaschinen machen
kann das hat echt praktisch bei den
bosch geräten
ich kann sie mit meiner home connect
verbinden und dann sehe ich eben auf
meinem handy wenn die wir schon fertig
ist muss sich nicht ständig nachschauen
also das ist schon gut wenn jetzt habe
ich hier sozusagen eine trockene wäsche
drin da habe ich die nächste welche
ladung zum waschen drin
hier habe ich die die ich gleich
aufhänge drin deswegen habe ich hier
immer meine kleiderbügeln und dann spare
ich mir auch ganz viel arbeit ich habe
aber auch viel platz zum aufhängen muss
ich sagen das heißt dass speicher und
wirklich doppelte arbeit ich hänge es
jetzt hier einmal auf und wenn es später
knitterfrei trocknet so dass ich es
nicht mal ein bügel guck mal
und wenn es doch noch zu bügeln ist dann
habe ich zumindest nicht mehr so viele
große falschen und damit gerade so
kleider wirklich schön trocknen achte
ich schon immer darauf dass hier oben
die naht auf dem bügel ist
ich mache auch die knöpfe zu dann
trocknet schon mal in die richtige form
und wenn man sich da echt so ein
bisschen mühe gibt dann spart man sich
im endeffekt danach viel arbeit und ich
muss sagen es hat etwas meditatives also
ich mach total gerne wochenende oder
auch unter der woche so zum abschalten
die wäsche hier meine musik deswegen
gibt es da auch immer viele videos davon
indem ich einfach selber filme und würde
das singe und tanze und euch auch zum
mitmachen motivieren weil es macht spaß
am ende ist alles schön sauber und
hoffentlich der schrank hier wieder leer
und der kleiderschrank oder voll
[Musik]
und meistens gucke ich dann einfach
immer schon mal wenn die wäsche schon
schön warm ist kann ich sie nämlich
direkt raus nehmen nach den gewürzen
antrocknen guckt mal schön durch
schwenken und durch schleudern und dann
trocknet sie wirklich super schön glatt
und vor allem ganz schnell
so spare ich mir ganz viel zeit und kann
wirklich in kürzester zeit ganz viel
wäsche abarbeiten
hab ich jetzt beim doppelklick leider
schon immer schön luftig aufhängen weil
jeanshosen gibt es auch einen guten
trick und zwar was ich dir auch auf
links dann drehe ich weitermache und
damit ich die nicht bügeln muss und sie
trotzdem schön glatt sind lege ich sie
erst mal zusammen um eine prinzessin
hallo kannst du mir später helfen mit
der wäsche nicht gut gehe und dann lege
ich die wirklich schönen auf ihrer naht
zusammen schön glatt in die spülmaschine
für kleiner quatschkopf in den im
trockner oder in der spülmaschine wird
es auch trocken aber nicht so schön
glatt was ich jetzt mit der jeans mache
ich lasse jetzt praktisch hier liegen
bis ich den rest eben erledigt diesmal
genau ich gucke
ich lasse jetzt hier praktisch liegen
bist du so ein bisschen gesetzt ist nach
23 minuten hänge ich sie dann erst auf
und dann sind wirklich schön die falten
geglättet und die jeans kann dann eben
auch coach ronny mich mal ich bin 1
meter 75 und du sag mal hersteller
gerade hin und du bist ein meter 12 8
uhr meine güte
hast du mal genug getrunken
trinkst du mal was und jetzt hab ich
schon wieder nach hause
also mache ich das halt auch echt gerne
am wochenende das ich dann wäscherei
macht dann die wünsche sofort auf hänge
und dann habe ich mir eine pause für die
kinder oder fürs kochen was das wusste
ich gar nicht gibt es im film ja klar
[Musik]
und dann geht es gleich nochmal weiter
frische ladung 2 ist jetzt auch fertig
es hat echt immer ganz eingespielt
es kommt hier über die schwarze wäsche
genug waschmittel habe ich noch drin
auto sanft hast auch und dann kann ich
nämlich hier drüben
moment die eine ist okay jetzt kann ich
hier drüben wieder mit der wäsche
weitermachen
und hier ist die wäsche auch echt schon
teilweise gut durchgetrocknet und dann
zeige ich euch gleich wird noch mit
bügel weiter geht und dann ist er schon
fertig
also ich habe ich jetzt noch eine wäsche
ladung die ich noch machen müsst wird
die weiße die schaffe ich aber auch ohne
euch was ich dann noch habe ist hand
waschprogramm da wähle ich dann hier
später einfach das handwerk programm
und gerade wenn ihr bhs thomas kraft
oder unterwäsche will ich auf jeden fall
immer so einen wäschesack nehmen denn
die bügel und auch die haken die können
nämlich andere textilien zerstören das
heißt alles immer schön hier einpacken
wenn ihr sportschuhe zum beispiel
waschen wollte gibt es auch diese beutel
oder man packt sie einfach in so ein
kissenbezug zum beispiel rein und dann
schon tier somit eben auch eure wäsche
das mache ich dann auch später da trenne
ich dann auch einfach zwischen den
farben weiß und schwarz oder bunt und
was sich hier noch habe sind die
handtücher habe ich einmal die hellen
und dunklen handtücher und da nutze ich
dann einfach das 60 oder sogar 90 grad
programm und das ist auch wichtig dass
ihr wirklich ab und zu auch bei hohen
temperaturen rasch damit eure
waschmaschine auch schön sauber ist ich
habe ja schon gesagt unsere
waschmaschine die stink nie weil ich zum
einen keinen weichspüler benutzer und
weil wir regelmäßig waschen und ich eben
auch mindestens einmal die woche die
handtücher einfach bei 60 oder sogar 90
grad waschen und so könnt ihr eben auch
die trommel immer reinigen der maschinen
pflege ist immer wichtig dass ihr auch
immer mal die gummi hände sauber macht
die dichtungen oder auch hier unten das
fach wo einfach eben auch hier wasser
ausgelassen wird es kann auch mal sein
dass sich da was darin verfängt eine
haarspange haargummi oder eine socke und
das solltet ihr wirklich alles
regelmäßig natürlich auch reinigen
[Musik]
die waschmaschinen pflege ist wichtig
aber auch die trockner pflege das heißt
da regelmäßig wasser and lernen und
natürlich auch das flusensieb reinigen
der reinigt sich wirklich schön von
alleine aber ich muss dann einfach die
flusen aus dem sie entfernen wieder
einsetzen und dann schon tier eben auch
eure geräte
jetzt werde ich hier drin alles erst mal
laufen lassen und kann weil hier alles
schön trocken ist ein bügelbrett
aufklappen und ein bisschen beginn weg
sagt ich mag bügeln nicht so gerne aber
ich habe jetzt echt fast nichts mehr
also ich glaube die meisten würden das
jetzt gar nicht mehr bügeln
ihr seht schon es ist wirklich schon
fast knitterfrei ich gehe da einmal
drüber aber so was wir hier ein overall
damit jetzt nicht mehr gebügelt der
schon glatt genug
und da würde ich eher faltenbildung als
dass ich sie herr ausbügeln und es ist
der einzige nachteil hier hatte der
wäscheraum hat sechseinhalb quadratmeter
es hat aber auch nicht mehr reingepasst
dass ich praktisch eine bügelstation
habt aber es mache ich dann meist hier
einfach vor der tür habe noch so eine
stange daneben und da kann ich dann die
wäsche schön auf dem main bügeleisen ist
jetzt schon bereit hier mache ich gleich
weiter und jetzt gibt es hier einfach
sachen die muss ich einfach nur dämpfen
so wie jetzt das kleid das würde ich
jetzt eher zerknittert wenn ich es vom
bügel unternehmen
das ist schön wenn alles glatt ist dass
ich sie noch kurz so aus dämpfen
und dann gibt's teile sowie dieses kleid
das muss ich jetzt schon richtig bügeln
übrigens wenn ich unterwegs bin mal in
einem hotel zum beispiel und ich habe
keinen bügeleisen
da kann man sich so war es einfach in
die dusche mit reinhängen davos hat
nicht nass wird und wenn ihr da duscht
mit warmen wasser dann glättet der dampf
sozusagen auch euer oberteil oder kleid
von der live act für unterwegs und beim
bügeln ist eigentlich nur wichtig also
wenn ihr darauf achten wollte
destilliertes wasser benutzen fürs
bügeleisen und natürlich das gerät aber
schon teure kleidung denn gerade
kalkhaltiges wasser kann eure wäsche ein
bisschen beflecken geht es ans weisse
rückstände
und ich habe am anfang auch immer da
nicht so wirklich drauf geachtet aber
irgendwann sieht man dann am bügeleisen
unten neben schon so eine gelbe schicht
und da spart man sich halt endlich zur
arbeit dreck und kosten und kaputte
wäsche
jetzt will ich heute bisschen morgen
bisschen dann habe ich die ganze woche
erledigt
[Musik]
ich würde ich jetzt noch ein bisschen
fertig die letzte wäsche die ich heute
jetzt schmeißen werde ist die handtuch
wäsche die mache ich es kann aber auch
sein dass es für heute versteht wird
aber dann kann ich ganz einfach das zeit
programm noch einstellen also wenn ich
weiß heute abend werde ich sie nicht
mehr trocknen dann warte ich sie auch
nicht mehr weil ich es einfach nicht in
der waschmaschine liegen lassen will
dann mache ich das zeit programm an und
kann teilen dass ich sie morgen früh 8
fertig haben will
entweder übers handy oder einfach über
die waschmaschine die meisten
waschmaschinen haben mittlerweile auch
schon zeit programm also nutzt es
wirklich ganz gerne und ich hoffe dass
ich euch mit meinem wäsche routine video
ein bisschen helfen konnte so ein
bisschen routine zeigen konnte wie ich
das hier so alles machen und ich muss
sagen muratow nicht wir haben uns echt
auch ganz gut aufgeteilt also wäsche ist
so mein part damit auch von mir nichts
kaputt gewaschen wird denn er trennt
nicht so gern die wäsche und er macht
dafür dann eben auch gern mal die küche
sauber oder die böden r4 sturm sagt
immer ganz fleißig das muss ich zum
glück nicht mehr machen und so teilen
wir uns alle auf sanieren und ella
helfen auch ganz fleißig mit also sobald
hier dann alles trocken ist hole ich
einfach die kinder her und sagt samira
kopf wollt ihr deine wäsche ab man holte
sie ab und kann sie auch wirklich schon
schön in ihrem kleiderschrank verstaut
ich hoffe euch macht ab sofort das
wäschewaschen sortieren legen und falten
genauso viel spaß wie mir wie gesagt
hört gerne lustige musik dabei schöne
musik singt und tanzt dabei schaut euch
meine story sun oder lasst einfach das
video parallel laufen
denn mit ein bisschen spaß macht
wirklich noch mal spaß macht das sinn
macht das finden
18 egal also mir macht auf jeden fall
viel spaß und ich bin glücklich wenn die
wäschekörbe danach wieder frei sind und
der erste der sich dann traut wieder
etwas schmutziges rhein zu schmeißen
wäre es dann schon ziemlich mutig naja
aber dann jede woche aufs neue oder also
viel spaß beim putzen waschen bügeln
hängen und legen und bis zum nächsten
mal
a
eigentlich routine video fertig aber ich
habe noch einige fragen gefunden die
nicht beantwortet wurden die werden
jetzt zusammen beantworten welcher
experte ja alles wirklich wetterexperte
muss sich gefahrlos ja was kann man
gegen das verblassen von dunklen
jeanshosen ton also bei jeans ist nur
einfach helle kaufen
aber oft ist halt auch bei jeans so wenn
man das erste mal wäscht sich die farbe
rausgibt der textilien die werden
praktisch da wird die faser gefärbt also
wird das garn ansicht gefärbt und dann
gibt's textilien die werden erst gelebt
und genäht und werden dann gefärbt für
sie günstigeren genau und das ist
günstiger weil man wirklich erst mal
alles nicht und macht und dann färbt und
dann gleich in die hand auch schneller
aus also da muss man echt schon auf
qualität achten und auf hochwertige
textilien und am anfang ist es ganz
normal dass jeans ausgleichen aber
später soll es eigentlich mehr fast
genau wieder drauf steht rolf singles
heißt es auf deutsch waschmittel
gleichen farben oder eigentlich war es
geschuldet neue klasse leistung
aber woher nehmen sie die motivation zu
löschen
ich finde es gar nicht so lustig weil
irgendwie brauchte immer die motivation
führen was ich meine die motivation zum
wäschewaschen ich eigentlich schon
daraus entstanden dass wenn die menschen
nicht wäscht dass du deinen schmutzige
kleidung hast mach die situation aber
ich bin halt saubere löchern gewählte
rechner tragen ausbilder wenn ich mich
morgens ansehen will ich mich frisch
fühlen und da muss man mehr motivation
geht nicht mehr außerdem demotivierten
nicht wenn die wäschekörbe voll sind
also mache ich lieber gleich weg schaust
du bei jedem stück ins etikett das muss
ich tatsächlich nicht mehr irgendwann
kennt man ja auch seine wäsche aber bei
neuer fescher die ich kaufe da schaue
ich sogar schon ins etikett bevor ich es
kaufe denn wenn auf dem etikett steht
dieses kleid darf sie nicht waschen
sondern nur chemisch reinigen zb kaufe
ich es erst gar nicht vor allem wenn es
um alltägliches kleid ist
und ansonsten achte ich schon sehr auf
textilien und ich kaufe zum beispiel
keine kleider wo ich genau sie da ist
jetzt schwarz weiß dunkelblau und
violett im wechsel und ich sehe schon
dass verwischt sich und die farben
bleichen aus dann kauf ich sowas
erstellung und welche nicht weiß auch
nicht was schwarz weiß bei hellblau oder
manchmal lang meist schon mehrere jahre
alt nach neun jahren das t shirt das man
jeden tag möchten nicht nur auswendig
warum riecht schwarze wäsche nicht so
gut wie weißer wand vielleicht liegt es
an deinem abschnitten als ich meinen
vielleicht herstellern anderes
waschmittel für schwarze wäsche aber ich
meine die wäsche riecht noch gleich die
gefragt wie versteht sich als die berge
von allein
ok ja ich mache dass ich macht der leser
fragt in welches fach muss ich das
waschpulver reinstetten aparter das ist
englisch männer frage jedes wissen viele
nicht weil da gibt es da einen strich
und zwei striche und auch geht es nach
weichspüler
es war ein strich man spricht hier von
ein bad das ist eine vorwäsche und habt
recht okay das einmachen 2 watt das ist
aber leider begriff du bist noch zu jung
dazu muss ich wissen
ok und da wo dieses sind drauf ist diese
diese muschel
das ist weiß spieler dieses fach
normalerweise nicht herzen mariens
gefragt wann sehen wir moratti wäsche
machen am liebsten ski leider sehen wir
das gar nicht der moral darf nicht mehr
die vision machen nachdem er damals mein
bild lederkleid bei 60 grad gewaschen
hat jetzt erst dann noch in den trockner
geschmissen hat da habe ich eine wild
ledertasche ja kein kleid werk und
seitdem darf keiner weg und ich muss
aber ehrlich sagen dass ich das ich
gerne welche was eigenes machen also er
darf seine eigene wäsche waschen aber
meine darf man nicht mehr weil das
system ob schwarz oder bunt ja und da
kann nichts falsch machen die zeitung
ja und ich werde auch wenn er meine
sachen mit wäscht und sie dann falsch
ist ja nicht da wieder eine politik
geben die meisten nicht und zwar
sneakers werden am riecht am besten
sauber in der spülmaschine ehrlich jetzt
ohne spaß in dem als nix oder caps haben
das heißt ihr habt so mützen wo er ab
und zu mal waschen wieder rein
geschwitzt hat dann tut es in der
spülmaschine machen
nein lose von eizo nichts falsches
gemacht als ich weg waren ich hoffe
deines niederlanden niemals in unserem
geschirrspüler wirklich disneyland sucht
dann nehmen sie bitte zur flasche
programm ich hoffe es aktuell nicht bei
unserer waschmaschine spiele sollen die
kunden spiegelte stellst du dein
waschmittel auf selbst herr wie deine
andere putzmittel nein also momentan
noch nicht ich weiß nicht was irgendwann
mal ist aber momentan habe ich die zeit
auch nicht unter das jetzt auch noch
selber hätten man muss man muss ja
ehrlich wenn man kann ja alles selber
man also wir kochen schon frisch ist
schon mal wichtig ja wir haben kinder
die müssen weg bringen und die musiker
wieder abholen in den kindergarten zum
beispiel bei allem habe ich jetzt ein
waschmittel finden was sonst alles im
argen liegen von euch machen für eine
coole geschehe werde die zeit und die
muße dazu habt aber aber das ist nicht
in ordnung ist aber auch gutes herbst
zwar erwähnt aber vielleicht nochmal
meine handtücher werden trotz reich
spieler immer hart was mache ich falsch
nehme immer pulver vollwaschmittel und
für handtücher ein trockner bis jetzt
nicht also zum einen ist falsch den
weichspüler zu benutzen
denn dadurch werden die frau die sachen
können sie keine feuchtigkeit mehr
aufsaugen und dabei spieler landet eben
auch auf deine haut und in der umwelt
zum anderen kann es einfach ein bisschen
essig dazu geben oder natron nach der
wäsche
dadurch hätte der karl geben auch
neutralisiert und es wird schön weich
oder du kannst sogar die handtücher
später noch mal ein bisschen bügeln
dadurch werden sie auch weich und
ansonsten wenn sie dann noch ein
bisschen hart denn ein schönes hautbild
kostenlos bei mir entstehen immer in den
t shirts löcher obwohl ich sie getrennt
war schon hast und tipp dafür dass da
hab ich mir auch keine gedanken drüber
gemacht aber eine andere zuschauerin
schritt dann drunter und das finde ich
echt aufschlussreich dass zum beispiel
auch so gürtelschnallen oder ph bügel
oder bh
häkchen die eben auch das müsste ich sie
beruhigen
dafür gibt es wird nicht wahr sein
schwarzes t-shirt immer hier vorne
ja das hat aber auch etwas anderes zu
tun mit den net ja etwas anderes zu tun
dass ich immer hier vorne
die löcher ich kenne da gibt es
irgendwas ich hab das mal gegoogelt ich
weiß dass ich irgendwas war damals
ich weiß nicht okay wir machen jetzt aus
ich glaube hier fragen das war macht's
gut macht's besser als bis zum nächsten
mal
nächstes mal geht es dann um dachrinne
reinigen gespielt
dachrinnen wie die sauber gemacht
mitarbeiter wie manager sascha stehen
die schiffe mit normal ich kann eine
anleitung machen für alle frauen und
männer geschirrspüler und genau unter
zeigen sich meist um eine schöne
geschichten und nein
doch das machen wir coole idee sei hier
guck mal kommt die letzte frage wie oft
muss bettwäsche gewaschen werden da
haben wir gestern im freundeskreis
darüber diskutiert wer alles dabei war
alles dabei von wöchentlich bis naja
dann wenn es unangenehm riecht also ich
bin da sind keiner morgen ich muss dir
jede woche waschen weil wegen der ich
mich wenn ich also ehrlich müssen
unterschritt mit wanzen
man müsste wirklich weil ihr habt es
schon 100 prozent habt ihr noch ein bett
hausstaubmilben kurz ganz nicht noch mal
ganz ganz groß im milden aussehen so
sehen die maus jetzt geht jeder seine
bettwäsche so ist jede alle wird wäsche
waschen okay weil diesen überall im bett
ist garantiere ich euch mal wie sauber
seit das hat jeder mehr oder weniger
positive positiv machen
macht's gut macht's besser